I'm going to just present very briefly
some edition that we had added to
Mathematica in the last few versions
regard mainly regarding how to deal with
the image metadata which is something
that we were like seriously lacking upon
before and now we have I would say like
pretty good way to deal with the
standard x3 access metadata and
something which is not here but is
coming and I mean I can promise this
coming back because i saw a merge branch
this morning is a XMP metadata images
and then i'll show you how to use a just
a teaser about how to use our machine
learning to to dig in your image
collections and these are because my
party as my colleague will have a talk
like only on that later on so i sees we
invite you to go there and lately just
demo few edition that we we we have in
this version we are going to have an act
in the next version in our computation
of photography sweet so let's start okay
so too is it big enough the text last
night line bigger let's try 150 then ok
so just not to be too dry i decided to
use pictures from my Armenian trip we
had the summer school in Armenia that
was very nice this summer and I took
some pictures without just with my phone
unfortunately because my camera was not
there with me Armenia but still I try to
took pictures everywhere and add some
metadata to that so you know just enough
of this will talk to work and it's not a
huge collection but you can see yes do
the evaluator please you you can see is
like almost 600 images and and if you
like it standard phone images so is you
see one image is like 13 megabytes and
if you track like the the full amount of
this collection is like roughly one
gigabyte so you
a the if you just want to look for
example I like information attached
images and I'm like this is just a
stupid travel example but like there are
a lot of microscopy images astronomy
images they have a like a lot of
information store in the metadata and
you don't want to import all of them
just to check what's inside and so the
way we do that now is we have a powerful
active importer and which is much faster
actually than importing all the images
and what's going on here if you do okay
so super fast but it feels faster
importing it okay so what's going on
this will just look into the image and
create an association with all the
properties that are story in the active
tag and this support like every stander
active tag and Charlie do support custom
tags right now or not yet not yet okay
and you can then like dig through this
and say like for example like this is
just one random image from the
collection and so you can like easily
see like this is our only one form but
like--imagine you have like multiple
cameras multiple devices you can check
the device you can check like when the
picture was taken if you have like GPS
information let me know if this one has
specifically now let's try another one
no has to be a little more than 39 yeah
this one has so so this says like all
the GPS information latitude longitude
altitude timestamps and of course the
normal of photography properties like
you can see aperture you can see if a
flash fired or not and by the way this
is like I don't know if you noticed we
had this data set container and the
interface for this has been refreshed in
the latest version so you can navigate
more easily into like sub then you can
now get into nested association like the
inside the other side and go back very
easily and comp you are so like this
doesn't a nice way to navigate into that
and of course you can only stratified
properties you are interested in and
deal with that so let's let's see now a
bit I have like some kind of like sample
analysis to show what you can do with
that so I said photography so one one
thing you can definitely check upon is
the exposure time of your picture and so
like for example like if i want to see
like at glance what kind of distribution
I had for my pictures I see like this is
the logarithmic distribution of my
exposure times so I see that like most
of the pictures were like probably in
day daylight condition but some of them
I visited some monasteries I didn't took
many nice picture but I was in two
churches and things so like some
pictures were like like with a greater
exposure value so you have another peak
and and of course like why what's the
benefit of using mathematica to do that
analysis of like for these kind of
things you can use a light room but the
point is like as I say like you had not
only photography that's not only photo
cameras which can generate pictures you
have like a lot of scientifical data and
with Mathematica you can build the tools
yourself so with a lot of like normal
photography software you have other to
rely on one specific set of features
like it's very difficult like some
plugins you have to look for like here I
for example I don't like the histogram
and I very quickly can build a like a
pie chart so this one here for example
will take all the exposures and put them
in a pie chart but oh like some of them
like this a deal too many so I can just
easily put a parameter here and change
my visualization function to dynamically
visualize like the most common exposure
times but I that are in my particular
collection and this is very neat because
I you can if you have to build a report
or like if you want to look yourself at
the data and mean for 90 or anything you
can very easily customize like integrate
this is all integrated in our technology
stack so you can use the visualization
function or I will show some Geographics
later or you can do analysis we think
it's supposed quantities if you notice
like we we took some curl into like over
here already for example like the
exposure time is is a time
so it is given in seconds so this
natively works with all the date plot
and all the like things in the language
with support times and and of course I
what ones do once you are done you can
like again they're easily like map your
own these are doing function on the data
set and you can create like in few lines
like report so like this is more or less
what I did with my picture hope focal
length is also interesting because the
phone has only one possible for coming
so I cannot move the the lenses and of
course like for example these are just
the most the most common ones but like
here just added one simple flag to to
see like the percentage of like other of
it's like I exclude before so like if
you're not satisfied this is very easy
to like for example I hear the
differences like just one line two line
of code like I can like very the way I
visualize the data exclude or include
data and this is something that I did
for our website it just doesn't show
very well because can you read the text
I don't know okay unfortunately given
that we only have one phone and one
image collection it wasn't so
interesting but we could use a flickr
account and analyze that and this was
produced with like three 4,000 or 5,000
picture from a flickr account over the
years and for example like this is this
is a plot of the percentage of picture
taken with the give given lens so and
this was like okay bit more than two
lines of code i cannot show you here
because i don't have a picture now on
this laptop but you can you can be like
as refined as you want in your basically
visualization so i mentioned gps data so
one neat thing is that you can do
computation with time example here i can
import their daytime tide from the exif
and then i have date instagram that like
very easily can plot like so this these
are my three pi her like two weeks is i
think it's quite clear that first two
weeks I was working the third week was
vacation and I think it shows this is
I hope the weekend and but do you have
also other functions like timeline plot
is a recent function and this is a
different form of visualization that
allows you to I mean if you have like we
used to have like we still have dateless
plot but that's like a function of time
here just like our events in time so we
decided was a nice thing to do I have a
native in building way to represent a
series of event possible for some labels
in this case I I put the images as
labels but it can be anything and but
this is the time part and there's also
them the space part of course and so
here you see I can import home sorry
this is i'm working with a branch and
there is a bug in the way i do we do
something so this is gonna fix it i hope
no one before yeah hmm oh yeah no of
course this is not gonna fix this the
other one is gonna be fixed so I mean
the point is that you can of course
import from the exit tag the latitude
and longitude and GPS altitude but then
you have to fix your reference system
like if you check the exif we have here
for example yeah you see the GPS
latitude and then the reference of
course because you can be in degree
north or south and also the longitude
can be east or west and the attitude can
be above sea level or below sea level so
it gets a bit cumbersome so we have some
shortcuts for example instead of
importing the exif you can directly
import the geo position and so this
thing here we'll just convert
automatically they will just like parcel
relevant information from the active tag
in the image and create for you a geo
position object that you're busy
chocolate is something that like is
smart in a sense so if i if i put inside
here for example this so you see this is
I I don't know if everybody is familiar
with quantities but if I do a full form
here
see this is a not a list of numbers is a
list of like numbers with units or two
equal quantities so this is in degrees
and then of the high decimeters and if
you plug this into geo position it will
just evaluate a nice compact form with
numbers so you can just use it I just
delete the missing the missing cases
here and I can use it in Geographics oh
yeah this here like this is just a row
later there's like a couple of straight
points because I my say layover was in
Moscow so like this an extra point but I
mean sitting in that mean heeya so like
now I can like move to another domain
and give them a team award from language
we have a lot of like geography
information traffic data I geography
function to work with geography data I
can like again very quickly optimize my
visualization just to show that this is
like the relevant part of my trip and I
cannot there's a tooltip yeah it shows
there's a tooltip with like the
geolocation mm I can get creative of
course like I had the height so for
example i can i can show with a color
function like army is very mountainous
region so like we went also hiking and
you see there's like some now i decided
to color it in black the lowest picture
and then while i move up to the mountain
here like this is like 1000 meters but
this was a pass he's like 230 no sorry
2030 and this is 3,000 so like again
like we're easily you can like play with
the color function like everything you
know you matemática and this like is a
very powerful way to show information
for like we and here I'm not even
touching the picture so just just I
think like this is a very powerful ways
like to pull information in Emma's
realize it and so okay now finally we
import some images what I was doing here
oh yeah yeah I have one last this is
like kind of neat is again not strictly
image processing but I like the fact
that we can do it we have this new path
so I can just show like the pictures
like layered on
the map with my actual trip and and I
was cruise like we we drove like 2,000
kilometers roughly I don't know how much
is that in miles but ok we can evaluate
so there is 1600 miles and and we have
this function five shorter store so I
can just put the geo position in and
this will is going to tell me I didn't
have to evaluate this ok so this takes a
bit because there are lots of pictures
and because this miss problems case
badly pop pop or so okay the the output
of this would be the shortest to between
all the points where the pictures were
taken so i can compare my trip with my
optimized trip and ok we optimize trip
is not so bad let me let me check and
was crucible so if i do these let's
multiply by 100 okay so i could have
been like eleven percent more efficient
but still not so bad and of course i can
then visualize this on the map so like
yeah i have no idea what from people
here who's the developer of fine
shortest path which team trust pool okay
okay i don't have much time so I'll just
move forward so another thing okay this
was just for the metadata part now i do
have some images in I just imported
thumbnails but lots of things are going
to work anyway so here lycée like I
notice like I mean in Armenia a lot of
monasteries and I took a lot of pics
from oral stories so let's say yeah I
know I won't like to dig into my
collection and find the picture of
monasteries for example because a lot of
other pictures are stupid eyes on me my
friends food I mean the usual stuff and
I mean that we have a computational
engine here so we should be able to
that the best thing we could do before
was just analyze kind of the distances
between pictures and there are many
definitions for that like for example
this is the this stupidest in the Emmy
Nyriss is a very powerful function it
has all those meters inside but by
default it does like the obvious thing
so when you call nice with list of
images if you just measure be equally
and distance between the pixels and of
course I if I want to find churches
that's not the best way so I have better
functions but there's there are like
many progress like for one thing they
are like kind of slower or a lot slower
because like there's more competition
involved and for example here i'm using
the Muturi information which is
measuring the joint probability so like
it does a bit better but still so I find
the future shoes I these are just my
first five images but this is still very
expensive to use and is not easily apply
ball to me if I want to reevaluate this
I cannot like save the other I measure
the distances but I I cannot like save
kind of a late veneers function is very
efficient but I cannot be the nearest
function here and and use that again
because I have to put in there all the
image data and it will be so anyway and
the psyche on the most important part is
that this is just looking at the pixel
values that it doesn't have like any
like better way to represent the images
but now we have through machine learning
and I not much time okay so it again
showed you but we have like another
people in machine learning we have like
a house machine learning capabilities
and those of course are applied to any
data included pixel values in images so
what I I did here is to build a fitter
structural function this of course takes
a while but one once but this is done I
can apply this to an image and basically
convert it to a rector and this vector
is not just like random numbers like
this vector here is like is this green
maps my image collection into a feature
space and those pieces are
representative of the content of the
image and n
and if you do this mapping you can do
this just by pixel value but you can
also use very powerful deep learning
method to obtain those sectors and they
will have built in classification
information so let me show like
practically what does it means like here
I'm building a variation of nearest that
I think we are going to have soon in the
language called semantic nearest but
right now I'm just creating this using a
nearest function and like as a distant
element like the features and is giving
it up to the images so now if i use with
some monasteries i find your searches
and the amazing thing is I like these
choices are very different like the
colors are different but the concept is
similar so this is the power that like
the powerful part of the machine
learning element of this and let's see
for example the difference if I do like
the semantic nearest on the monastery I
find like mainly you see like there are
basically all the images of churches and
if i do the just normal nearest with
equal DN distance is something which is
similar in color but it doesn't really
have any semantic closeness to the
original thing and then of course i can
we say you have I think in the notebook
but we have like more advanced function
to show like to cluster eyes images we
can do many things we can build
clustering trees we can collect them in
then the Grahams we can find cluster
free images and for example I these are
some image clusters in which i
explicitly use custom function to find
groups subgroup singh images and I mean
this stuff is very powerful and but I
don't enjoy all of it now and but the
point is like all the things that you
can use for data it's easily standable
to images and we have a huge number of
images like is nice to be able to
automate those procedures like sometimes
you don't really want to tag every
measure yourself so of course like the
human element is essential but if you
can like guide it and like it's a big
help if you have like this ad eighteen
ninety percent of the work done by the
machine already so you just have to
refine it the last part is that i wanted
to show just because i personally like
it and I'm working on that is the
but another thing I'd we support like
way to deals to deal with image stocks
and Marcos down here is showing is the
guy with a microscope and so he's
showing how to deal with like more
images taken it like same subject
multiple focus rings here i have like is
very badly aligned because it's just
phone pictures but same subject with
multiple exposure levels and why do you
want to do that because sometimes you
have like for example i hear a nice guy
but you have something in front which is
dark and you cannot really see that so
the trick is like to take multiple
pictures and then try to merge them
together and and this is like since
couple of version is very easy and you
are still working of that to make it
more powerful and more automated and for
example he here just i have to align the
picture and when they are done I just
build a mask to remove the part which is
like not align your cause of course like
if I show you these different pictures
like that the content is moving around
because my hand was something not so
stable so I can align them and just find
the misalignment misaligned region and
once that is done I I can just throw it
away and then combine my pictures
together so this takes like the best of
every picture and put like commands it
together and this we had like since
couple of versions oh it's a nice
addition we have this is fairly new so
we have this method for function in
paint that generate sectors and this is
the code texture synthesis that looks
into the image and because I really
don't like the fact i had to cut away
part of the image here so i can just
create them out like another mask using
my original mass but i used to cut it so
I say okay just look inside the good
part just not too far from the border
and look there and synchronize some
textures so I can basically you see this
part here is new but it's been filled in
with the content of the image let me
sync the dies like so I I go back to
original size and I can see them oh I'm
done and the very very last thing that
we are working on here this is the kind
of preview it was just in my build is
that to find a way to insert just
I in the pixel values in the normal low
dynamic range image is basically to
combine everything together and this
image is similar to the other one but is
more spread out in a sense that it
contains a lot of the information both
in the dark and in the light part of the
image and why do you want to do
something like this because when you can
like manually so i'll just show this one
manually turn them up the image so like
basically you can choose yourself how to
combine the bright part on the black
part and also for like created effect
creative effects or like to show more
information in the same image and we
don't have any more times and much more
time zone I'm done thank you
[Applause]